[Music]  Nick Viall has an enemy it's not a fun  feeling The Bachelor started his journey  on Dancing with the Stars Monday night  but one famous face is urging fans not  to vote for him you yes William Shatner  the actor tweeted quote my goal for  Dancing with the Stars is to knock  Bachelor Nick out ASAP he explained his  issue with vile saying he lives up to  the homonym of his last name watch andy  Dorfman's bachelorette season where he  started this vile journey the Star Trek  star also does not expect Nick to stick  with fiance Vanessa Grimaldi saying he  would not be surprised if the 36 year  old went on bachelor in paradise again  there have been days that have been  difficult vile has responded with a  simple frowny face  [Music]